i'm back baby oh
[Music]
oh feels good i've been on a break
in case you haven't noticed did you miss
me
you missed me just say it i missed you
too it's okay
so i roll the intro what the [ __ ] did
you do with the reddit
i was gone i'll get so what's your
submissions in the next episode
before we begin i have an exciting
announcement
after years of begging i finally decided
to do a face reveal that's right i'm
finally coming clean
and doing the face reveal this is a big
deal
this is a monumental moment of this
channel
i understand the implications i
understand the anxiety
i understand the expectations but here
we go i've realized that the only way
for me to stay relevant at this point
it's necessary for me to do this corp's
husband
no face cam no face reveal massively
popular
dream no face cam no face reveal
massively popular and now pewdiepie
no face cam no face reveal massively
popular so therefore i am doing a
reverse face reveal sorry reverse my
face
not that way here we go nope
frame first oh that feels weird it
already feels
strange everything is different now
actually
that makes me want to look at really
quick before i do this pewdiepie
face reveal i remember when i did it the
first time i looked like a little dweeb
where am i it was my thousand sub
here it is oh it's 2500. there i am
in 2011. revealing my face to the
internet for the first time
and apparently people have been getting
this in their recommendation
this guy looked like someone who would
marry an italian girl
damn it's weird having your life on the
internet man i realized that now that
i've
gone the most handsome phase of 2020
it's all gonna be downhill from there so
i gotta live up people's imagination
from now on
all right it's time take a long hard
look this is the last time boom
reverse face revealed i haven't picked
my avatar yet so i thought
why don't you guys on the pewdiepie
submission subreddit
help me pick my 3d avatar because every
they all have this image right
and it's not this one
oh man oh god what am i doing all right
let's
let's get into the lion they don't know
that this meme has audio
f off
i'm so glad i came back from a break why
am i looking in the camera when i'm
speaking there's nothing to look at
anymore oh my god i forgot about lizard
lava again jesus all right next week
lizard lava
next week sorry felix but my mom said
that i'm the most handsome man
i will be taking your award for most
handsome man now
email my manager my mom for i'll email
you mom
what's your email oh what the [ __ ] i
forgot about this
this is back when i used to before my
face reveal
my reverse face this is in singapore
it's such a there was a weirdest green
room of all time
filthy frank was there obsessed
girlfriend was there
it was a good time that's right li
that's her name i remember now oh [ __ ]
oh i like this guy i like this guy a lot
what's his channel means perfect oh
no one links his channel what is this
amazing new profile pic submission all
right maybe i should change to this one
now
hey now that i've done a face reverse
face reveal it actually makes sense with
the whole sensor
wave pattern cut that all makes sense it
was foreshadowing guys you should have
seen it coming
controversial youtuber is finally making
a comeback af
even after nearly five year absent
me wondering who i've been watching for
the last five years oh that's felix
phyllis kajelberg
should i get a different name now that i
reverse face reveal
like mark has his like anti right
or the evil markiplier and jack has
antiseptic eye
maybe this could be my this is just
clickbait by the way it's because i
i signed a deal with the facebook thing
to have videos on facebook
because that's a thing and they decided
to make it seem like
i was making a comeback which is a thing
i guess
journalism pewdiepie wins the most
handsome
face of 2020 twitter read it hell yeah
look at this face how can you argue i
don't get it
all right for this episode i will let
side pick my avatar
sign look at this face beautiful thank
you
i like how this confused so many i said
i was gonna put the highest
voted post as my avatar and there it is
it's beautiful take a long harder look
at that beautiful face
felix ain't big great just in time i
have a surprise for you
so marzia do you know what our house
really needed
our entire kitchen is made of ovens
you could bake so many cakes now hell
yeah
look at my i think blank she dropped
huge pp as always how they animated it
again
[Laughter]
listen you don't have to do this
you do have two children i have a two
child like
i forgot about it hey listen stay here
and you just walk away you know i won't
tell i won't tell anyone
i swear i'll be back in in a few minutes
still here i will be of course thank you
thank you so much i i won't forget this
it's genuinely terrifying dude okay i'll
stay i'll say it'll stay
i'll see
who knew jaden animation was so
terrifying i keep
looking into the camera all right
playing minecraft until my wife tells me
to stop
get a lot of this sin get a lot of this
idiot who doesn't know the difference
between a simp
and a good husband that's right i did
ask martian
tell me to stop myself would literally
never tell me
[Music]
yeah every time i go on break you guys
just [ __ ] it all up don't you
what the hell is wrong with you
unpopular opinions
about felix wow felix coming back from
break new content
thank you guys so much you are too kind
i'm popular opinion i'm glad pewd
stopped playing some games as he often
seems genuinely uninterested and bored
i don't know maybe he's just sleepy
yeah cause they are boring it's
minecraft all day every day that's the
only game that's fun
i apologize for my lack of attention
span guys
unpopular opinion i like felix's meme
videos more than his gaming videos
i enjoy watching meme review of why you
life lose bring back show when
but whenever he uploads a gaming video i
just never watch them because i don't
really find it as an
enjoy minecraft oh except minecraft
there we go
we're the same we're the same felix is
worse
youtuber than pewdiepie
damn it i'm probably finna feel like
this is not an opinion this is just
a theory would like to reinvent himself
as a creator but doesn't know how to do
it without shutting out his long
time fans just go and come back please
what is that why it's so weird when
people have thoughts on the internet
about what your thoughts are it's like
well i don't
wait why he just needs to find content
that makes him excited
i am so excited about this reverse face
reveal guys
unpopular opinion even though the fans
are getting more involved browsing
reddit is just a cheap way to make
content
uh that's not in a popular opinion
that's just facts bro
listen i know it doesn't take a lot to
do this
but i love it it's so much fun this is
my favorite video to shoot
recording them every week genuinely
because i i get to interact with you
guys i'm so glad
the y has been the best thing i've done
in this channel cheap content sure it's
always
sitting in front of a computer playing
games like i don't know
nothing's really changed but i do hope
to make some more
high effort videos eventually i don't
know who knows
we'll see don't pressure me okay
[Music]
oh no oh no
oh no no no no
oh god oh no
i just realized now that i don't have a
face reveal there's
less effort for scythe to edit so
therefore
i can cut sides pay right side
i'm joking or am i i'm joking
they should add dog bets in minecraft so
when dogs die they respawn yes
can't they do like an ender portal or i
don't know something cool with it you
can resurrect your dogs
please mojang no cave update we need
this dog update
dog demon portal update come on when the
teacher asks a class for a girl
volunteer and your friend shouts out
your name
funny it's not funny you're just being a
[ __ ] idiot and you're not clever
you're not funny you're just a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and wipe that smug ass [ __ ]
smile off your face [ __ ]
okay go [ __ ] yourself god damn
2017 pewdiepie was a savage i miss
toxic salty pewdiepie
oh my god everyone's always doing this
our 20 2012 pewdiepie was the best no
2013 pewdiepie was the best
no 2014 no 20 50 pewdiepie that's the
best one
2069 pewdiepie haha that was my favorite
look at him he has a little hat on oh my
god
look he's wearing a little head that's
so cute
rest in peace roll this is so
sad history repeats itself guys
well your tally wife tells you no pasta
for you
but you realize she didn't say anything
about pizza nice
good meme made me laugh well done see i
missed this [ __ ]
oh look at that girl and all the amazing
fan art that's sick dude
i said i've been a little bit harsh on
you guys lately but i also gotta say
you guys are some of the swedish people
i know i mean that
see i can be sincere now because i'm not
on camera anymore this is great
appreciate you guys i love this icon
i think i'm gonna change to this next
this is my new icon
it's beautiful why
[Music]
so when i was gone you guys brought back
dead memes well done guys
well done pewdiepie nice
good details i like it
me about to post the tv simulator meme
seeing everyone posting dead memes and
realizing i can't
because it's still relevant 20 billion
downloaders
can't be wrong download tuber simulator
today
it's free water sheep dies in water
built a temple for it
dies in water gets replaced
i'll build him a temple as soon as i
beat the wither
if i can make it that far no
why you mother nature oh
i look like chubby felix oh
you look good man you share the face of
the most handsome man
you're halfway there my brother
oh god why is this so funny
yeah pewter got a cool pc and doesn't
even use it
me whose pc won't even run java
minecraft i
feel this because i was out of town for
a week and i couldn't play
minecraft because i didn't have my
laptop either if i try to run it on this
shitty ass computer and it doesn't work
and i know i could have just bought
another computer but i don't want to do
that
so i feel i'm just like you guys i'm
just like you guys i get this
felix car marzia's car is this part of
the dead meme thing
i'm just kidding i'm kidding guys
this took me a minute they don't know i
run a youtube channel
dude i remember when i was working there
and it was
almost over my shift was almost over the
fact that i could go back
to start making videos again was so
[ __ ] exciting
it was such a fun exciting thing in the
background like i didn't even mind the
job
just because i was so excited about
youtube in my part time
wait did i say that 2020 was gonna be
the worst year
is that true do we have the source for
that i'm a goddamn prophet dude
why is no one talking about this i
predicted
holy [ __ ] here we go a terrible 2020
let's
get it let's make this the worst year
ever guys
[Laughter]
we did it we made it the worst year ever
guys and then i said let's make 2021 a
great year
hell yeah have you guys been joining the
reading and the exercise
i hope so book review coming
monday
[Music]
oh poor 30 year old man what a shame
big peep you get right there hell yeah
does your chair do this
[ __ ] i can't even show side can you i
won't i won't cut your race just
just just edit it and just edit so i'm
doing it
hell yeah here's some kid yeah oh
top up next week decides my next
instrument
that the flute is stale now
let's get it gamers
we should add these great submissions i
can't believe i didn't see this
i'll send this to tuber simulator
what is a hairline day stop it this is
not going to be my avatar all right this
is not a i can pick anything i want
get pewdiepie's dad as hell's
embarrassing challenge source by felix
he has none because i was the perfect
child in every single way possible
true we used to call you felicia because
you like dressing up as a girl when you
were a kid
next meme yeah shout out to inside
emphasis
such a sick submission i love it a lot
of people are asking just like why does
he do the waves because it looks cool
that's literally it this should stop
soon
that's fear in that red bunny's eyes
pure fear
i want to see the bunny playing
minecraft when a 30 year old swedish man
likes your meme impressive [ __ ]
thank you you're welcome guys
paying respect to the skeleton to do the
360. oh [ __ ]
i respect that i respect that
oh my [ __ ] god
why does my sick alright march almost
gets the best fan art god damn it
holy [ __ ] that's terrifying everyone is
talking about pewdiepie playing
minecraft but no one is paying attention
that pewdiepie died in 2014. this is so
sad
felix schelberger has been halting
holding the lantern ever since
i still can't talk apparently that's
great
[Laughter]
in his class guarded you're getting in
the cameras
oh man it's funny because it's true my
sister earning her bachelor's degree
and doctrine degree in nine years me who
got big pp from periods in 19 years
let's go big pp did they actually do
anime welcome back we're done with your
side of the deal
for helping us build our new temple we
were able to kill
through drowning without getting noticed
i hope you're happy now
that is so dark no
sweat is not evil still get big pp but
no
longer democracy
oh god we have such good options and
this is what won
people beats bts to most handsome face
of 2020 wayne
that's right bts suck it that's what you
get for unfollowing me bts
huh better think twice about him
following me i have followed you too by
the way
i don't give a [ __ ] k-pop stance they're
mine now
they're all mine i have an anime avatar
now so i've edited in the anime avatar
oh damn this is so cool god damn it
maybe i'll add some of these
later on that's cool guys i'm really
excited to be back it feels good i
i genuinely miss you guys i hope you had
a great time up
so did i but i'm ready to with new
energy
to get back into playing minecraft
[Music]
every day all day let's get it
imaginary brofist boom hit it
[ __ ] yes see you guys tomorrow look at
the graph i forgot about that
cocoa mellow almost about to beat us
genuinely please subscribe